welcome back numia vest drives to create
more job opportunities combat poverty
expand Investments and so much more so
let's learn more about the goals of the
company with this next segment sponsored
by SMG Media Group joining us now is
Sally Osmond Sally how are you
hi thank you so much for joining us can
you tell us a little bit just about
yourself and how you started on this
journey
um so my name is sunny Osman I've been
in cyber security for about 25 years now
and digital transformation I started my
career as a tech in um and Abu Dhabi
police
installing Radars and configuring
networks for
ticketing systems and DMV
and you know I progressed through my
career in the United States in the last
23 years
so I was um
with GE heading a technology audit and
then I after that I went to Saudi aramco
as a risk officer on an advisory
capacity and then after that and I went
to Amazon aw web services as a principal
security advisor and then I recently
stepped down as the chief security
officer of the international monetary
fund so you know I moved around from one
industry to another
yeah and it sounds like it's really
evolved over time congratulations on
everything so far and how do you use
your background in cyber security to
really Advance Boards of publicly held
companies
so um
publicly held companies has a corporate
directors have fiduciary responsibility
when it comes to risks in general and
digital risks and cyber security risks
is a major component of that and a lot
of people don't realize that the um it's
not a technology issue a lot of people
recognize and deal with the cyber
security as a
um it's just a network thing you know
someone else in the network will handle
that and in fact the with the Privacy
regulations and most of the regulatory
framework nowadays has puts a burden on
the board of directors so through
um through
excellent
organizations such as the National
Association of the corporate directors
and diligent we do actually have a lot
of education programs when it comes to
um cyber security and risk oversight so
we've um
we've established that with when
it comes to um the um
the the publication that was published
in 2017 a Digital Risk assembly uh cyber
risk oversight I was responsible for the
digital wisdom and merger of that
acquisitions
segment and there's also
um
you know a lot of seminars and case
studies that talks about the importance
of
privacy regulations in that space well
Sally thank you so much we have to wrap
up now but thank you again to SMG Media
Group for sponsoring the segment and for
more information you can visit
nubiafest.com for more